I think YouTube shorts is very big for
this audience I'm obsessed with it
because it's searched the amount of
people that search YouTube when they're
considering to move to a town is
staggering it's second behind Google I
know that I'm moving in a year to Newton
Massachusetts and literally the second
place people will type in Newton Mass
schools Newton Mass Parks country clubs
YouTube is number two you started
vaynermedia right now housed under
vaynerx right in the middle of 2008-2009
recession that's right
similarly we started sirhant you know I
was a real estate agent built a big team
left in 2020 people started getting sick
we moved forward anyway we launched in
September 2020
um uh at a tough time right and in both
cases I think there's this underlying
belief that times of Crisis can breed
Innovation and success and so there's
there's never a bad time to launch a
good business correct right like if
you're capable like we are
you know in a weird way to your point
there's a lot of opportunities that
happen during times of trouble that
wouldn't be there during times of
prosperity uh both prosperity and ease
like we had prior to this last couple
years or what we're going through right
now genuinely requires operational
capability and talent and execution and
grit and patience and all the things
that matter but make sense
yeah so now where we are in our world
most people who are here are in the real
estate family and mortgage rates are on
the rise the real estate market is now
facing new challenges you got low
inventory and slow sales in one market
you've got some inventory and fast sales
and others
you put yourself in our shoes
what practical strategies are you
thinking about
what shifts would you recommend I got a
sales people today yeah so here's my
biggest thought right I'm tuning thank
you for everybody in the chat I love the
context because it allows me to use
things like in Ohio or Las Vegas or
London
um oh London Canada excuse me
um
there are things you can control and
there's things that you can't control
nobody on this call controls interest
rates nobody in this call controls some
of the variables that we saw with like
Florida and and California have these
Dynamics Texas and New York have these
Dynamics Ontario has this Dynamics you
know so everyone here I'm looking at
Boise and Boca Raton are going to act
differently Sweden definitely is going
to act differently than Bell Harbor
Florida so we are there's a lot of
things that are macro
what I do during times like this is
focus on micro what can I do so if I'm a
real estate agent in any Market whether
it's easier or the hardest in today's
exact second what I focus on and you
know I'm very consistent about this and
you've benefited from this greatly
I think the one thing you can control is
creating demand
right you can control creating demand
and I think demand Creation in real
estate properly has talked about a lot
of blocking and tackling for newbies
cold calling and networking we don't
know all that stuff
I will continue to yell from the top of
the mountains that making content on an
individual basis from Sean Walsh on here
to Emil gorgeous to Toby Swank that you
know Walla Walla by the way a place that
makes great wine you know for Toby his
ability to make content literally
actually ironically even a video on a
Facebook reel of him tasting
a Walla Walla cab from leonetti and
talking about the market that's it just
literally six minutes glass of leonetti
Cabernet talking about the market he may
get a client Ryan because he's drinking
leonetti Cabernet like for example for
me I know that 99 of the people right
now when I say leonetti Cabernet it
doesn't even register half the audience
right now doesn't even know what I'm
saying and even people that know what
Cabernet is in wine they don't know
exactly what I'm actually referencing
and so you have the ability to control
demand creation and I believe demand
creation happens in networking
I think it happens in cold emailing I
think it's cold calling I think it's
direct mail but but by a country mile
the best way to create demand in today's
world is to create as much social media
content as you humanly can around what
you know don't fake the funk if you're
in year three as an agent that's going
to have a different knowledge base than
Year 17. talk about what you know don't
you know don't fake it till you make it
talk about what you know how you know it
what you're seeing and then like the
example I used with the gentleman with
the leonetti cab bring your personal
life into it whether that's golf
immediately right four people in the
chat talked about my Aaron Rodgers
t-shirt and my jet spandom there's I'm
going to say this very clear vaynermedia
which is now probably like a 350 million
dollar a year Revenue business Vader X's
right
I believe that a million dollars of our
revenue is because I personally am a New
York Jets fan that there is a CMO
marketer out there that feels a
closeness to me because in our both of
our sadness of our Jets fandom and
subconsciously she or he has given us
business without even realizing it and
that's how the world actually works you
know I feel a connection towards you
when you talk about your story of your
come up
because even though it's not exactly the
same as mine it has enough of it in
there that just makes me feel a
different way towards you in the
beginning of when I first became aware
of you that matters and I think that
people need to focus on demand creation
no matter how little sales are happening
right now if you're creating 37
potential clients in 18 months because
of your dinner parties your Barbecues in
your backyard you're knocking on doors
or you're making six pieces of social
media content a day talking about the
market and yourself and your family and
whatever you've comfortable with doing
the work you're doing the work
yeah
versus versus what you know people are
like oh I'm looking again Tamp Kelly B
saying Tampa's cold it's like what can I
do about it and and I'm sure Kelly's not
that person she's all the other way but
I know that 90 of people are playing
that game well I got so unlucky interest
rates went up just as I got going like
they just start to complain about things
that they can't control they blame
everybody but themselves you can wake up
this morning like think about what's
happening right now you and I and all
these wonderful people decided to
allocate the time to do what we're doing
now all from different angles all for
different reasons but let's call it
Spain a spade all of that is in the
interest of us all putting in the work
100 something that I say all the time is
take care of the work the work takes
care of you when it's busy grab buckets
right when you're closing grab buckets
catch all the rain and then make sure
you hold on to those buckets and other
times and then go out and go build more
buckets right build those buckets and
build those buckets now you talk about
content we have there's lots of agents
at sirhant and all the markets that
we're in now uh
uh who are completely comfortable
getting in front of a camera getting in
front of their phone you get this
question a lot but I just want to I want
to hit on it
what do you tell the person who's
completely uncomfortable that's just not
them they don't want to fake it till
they make it they're not they're not
dancing on Tick Tock they're not even
good writers right they don't want to go
and blog on LinkedIn
I I tell them two things one you build
brand yeah I tell them two things one
you don't have to I I'm not sitting here
trying to convince anyone that they have
to sure on the flip side
on the second piece it's more important
I believe most people don't create
content because they're scared of
judgment and I tell them that high
school is over and even if your first
video is a little clunky and you don't
like the way you look or this that the
other thing anybody who leaves a snarky
or nasty comment is hurting themselves
has nothing to do with your life and the
silent majority that are consuming it
that are considering to do business with
you is far more interesting than the
three people that are so hurt that they
want to leave a nasty comment that your
dress isn't pretty or you don't know
what you're talking about and so other
people's opinions is devastating like
cat said in the comments it's my number
one it's insane to me how that
ultimately is my mission in life which
is oh this is a very simple game of
confidence versus insecurity that's all
it is I'm empathetic to it we all have
confidence in certain areas
than others but I couldn't recommend
people more to make themselves
uncomfortable and and I would tell the
other group a lot of people say Gary I
don't need it I'm the dominant real
estate agent in my area like I'm good I
I just I always think that's scary like
the greatest champions in every sport
eventually hit a day like Kobe Bryant
was great but even in his last season
there was a lot of off nights and you
know and you know Muhammad Ali got
knocked out by Trevor burbik and nobody
even knows who Trevor burbik is and so
you know I think you know father time in
sports happens and father time in
business happens I think that the
audacity that you don't need it is
exactly what a young lion like me will
take advantage of there is a 24 year old
you and me Ryan right now in the market
where somebody's overly confident and
they will Tick-Tock and Facebook and
Instagram their way into a problem to
that 30-year vet oh for sure for sure we
um uh when I find those agents I usually
reach out to them and ask them why they
work where they work and they should
come here it's one of the reasons we
have Sergeant Studios which is our
in-house production company and we have
ID lab which is our in-house creative
agency helping agents in a way that I
never had at the firm I was at before
and in a way that I could never find any
other brokerage to really help create
personal Brands to generate leads in
their sleep 100 business in organic ways
that you ordinarily wouldn't be able to
do where do you find today
underpriced attention
LinkedIn is obsessed I'm obsessed with
LinkedIn for everyone here because
people's mind a couple things one you
and I and everybody in here
um
when we go to tick tock versus when we
go to Instagram versus when we go to
LinkedIn we are in three totally
different psychological mindsets
right I don't think you are going to
LinkedIn well actually you might because
I do this actually work because we're
degenerates we may go into LinkedIn at
11 15 p.m and go through the you know
feed but most people go to tick tock
there because that's mindless
entertainment sure versus 11 12 a.m like
right now when they're going into
LinkedIn because they might be doing
business development when our content
may then show up so LinkedIn is acting
like Facebook several years ago it has
crazy ad targeting everyone here can
literally target
employees of the biggest employer in
their town and especially think about
how smart what I'm about to say you know
there's a fast growing
company in your area and people are
moving into the area because of this
fast-growing company you can literally
run ads about you being a real estate
agent or what you know about the town to
employees of that company and start
becoming the refer people will see it
and refer people or the person that you
want to get to will see it because you
actually targeted the employees of
Snapchat in Venice when Snapchat was
exploding in Venice linkedin's a monster
the ad targeting not only that the
organic reach you could have everybody
here could have zero followers on I'm
putting my LinkedIn in here everyone
literally feel free to follow me for the
purpose of research here's my LinkedIn
click it you'll start to see my content
in feed you will be blown away by how
well and how many people that reaches
and don't forget this is a referral
industry so you could say hey I'm
selling in Tampa but again somebody may
like you because of what you said when
you're making your content on LinkedIn
and may refer you and so I just think
linkedin's a monster I think YouTube
shorts is very big for this audience
I'm obsessed with it because it's search
the amount of people that search YouTube
when they're considering to move to a
town is staggering it's second behind
Google I know that I'm moving because my
husband or my wife is being relocated in
a year to Newton Massachusetts and
literally the second place people will
type in Newton Mass schools Newton Mass
Parks country clubs
YouTube is number two and if you're
making YouTube short content you're
showing up in that especially if you're
smart on how you title if you make a
video and it's titled the school systems
in Newton Mass and your real estate
agent talking about the schools in
detail
that becomes the reason you get the lead
something we do
um within fair housing yeah something
that we do in in the Hamptons that we
started doing with Studios is started
doing neighborhood guides neighborhood
tours and teaming up with other
Publications so it's not specifically
tied to us and we're doing this in Miami
and we use LinkedIn a lot as well in in
you know in South Carolina we just
opened in South Carolina Chris Bose is
leading that charge and you drive around
you see every major company like
Gulfstream and so running ads directly
against Gulf Stream and then you see the
at gulfstream.com emails from potential
Sellers and purchasers just start coming
through because you they feel spoken to
right they feel they feel heard
you know something there's something
happening in comments and you just did
something I don't know the full details
on Fair Housing requirements and
complying that's another thing that
drives me crazy right is how many people
use law as a reason not to do something
it's very easy to comply yes you might
not be able to do something the same way
a diet soda can or a sneaker can right
but
um you can absolutely absolutely always
comply back to Megan who asked in the
comments how do I get more engagement
out of YouTube I go you know host more
she says I am but not gaining followers
Megan the next thing you need to do is
post different things right one of the
things that you know the the definition
of insanity is doing the same thing and
thinking you're gonna get a different
outcome a lot of people you know will
make a video of themselves especially in
this industry and they make 30 of them
it doesn't click that's okay not
everybody crushes on video what you may
want to do is flip the camera over walk
the house and talk maybe the visual of
the house and your voice is the right
concept for you know for the content so
try different formats try different
formats maybe you just do audio no video
at all and then just have an image like
there's a lot of different ways to make
content Haley post as many times as you
can a day I'm being dead serious now
posting 15 times on Tick Tock is crazy
but posting three times in Tick Tock and
three times a LinkedIn and two times on
Twitter or X and three times on threads
and one two times on Facebook and one
time on YouTube like you can get your 15
from more Distribution on a single
platform four is where you probably want
to max out on
advice
all anyone's talking about right now is
I just want to sip topics for a second
is AI
you've talked about it a lot a lot of
interviews a lot of videos there's no
doubt that it's reshaping Industries
right it's it's including the market
agency space right including including
what you're doing and in our case real
estate how do you see AI impacting the
world of sales people in the service
sector and then more practically what
tips and strategies are you thinking
about now to suggest for the agents who
are here
there's a there's a wave coming it's
called Ai and everyone here is on the
beachfront right at the front and we
have two choices most people are putting
their head in the sand and this is their
strategy
a couple of people are are buying or
building a surfboard grabbing it
watching videos on how to surf and are
prepared to catch that wave
so first of all my first practical piece
of advice is every single person here
who's like AI hate AI it's ruining
the world it's bad I'm scared of it
I've got good news for you just like
your parents hated the internet hated
cell phones hated email hated iPhone
it's gonna happen anyway
so either you decide to start getting
educated or you decide to retire which
is fine
um
what do I think is going to happen I
think a lot of mundane actions are going
to be ai'd out so the person here who
crushes cold emails
is going to lose her or his Advantage
because I'm going to be able to type in
write me the best cold email to sell a
house in Tampa Florida enter and it's
going to work
and then that means everyone can do it
thus it becomes commoditized
somebody asked is Instagram dead in the
chat no Instagram's harder now because
everybody makes Instagram nine years ago
11 years ago when I was yelling that
everyone should do Instagram it was
easier because if you made one a lot of
people saw it because there was less
content and a lot of attention it's just
supply and demand just like housing and
homes and apartments so you know we're
still on threads are you threading every
day yeah I'm threading every day you
know why even though it's down 70 from
the height of the first week 30 for me
is still a lot of eyeballs and there's
higher consumption than there is on
Twitter by percentage the audience is
smaller because it's kind of getting its
legs underneath it but that's um I am
threading every day I'm Xing every day
um and and I'm I'm doing everything
every day because I believe that no
different than bench ads and billboards
and direct mail and and being the head
of the PTA and sponsoring the little
league baseball team if I'm trying to
sell homes I'm selling on attention and
reputation yeah and the one thing about
social media is nobody can stop me and I
don't have to pay this is the thing that
drives me crazy you if you want bench
ads or bus stop ads or Billboards or
newspaper ads or direct mail they charge
you this shit's free and
everyone's like oh the algorithm
me I'm like it's free right
it's free yes
you you bring up a a good point you you
do so many things
right one of the big things we talk to
our agents with is they're building
their teams right we have agents that
join Sirhan they want to build their
personal Brands they want to double
their sales price get to higher price
points they're using Studios ID lab all
of our resources it's all super cool
but then they have no time to breathe
right they're operating every five
minutes they're all over the place
how do you look at 2023 the rest of the
2020s in terms of building building
operational teams figuring out systems
and process because most sales people
are here because they know how to sell
they know how to show they know how to
close they know negotiate if they don't
we work on it but you run a lot of
companies you do a lot of things you've
got V friends you've got family you're
everywhere you're here right now
does everyone just need to delegate
everyone's got to hire you gotta judge
yourself less when when when you're
juggling Authority balls if three break
you know one a father could judge
themselves that you know like hey you
have a friend and acquaintance and Ryan
but that's not more important than a
child and you've decided to allocate 20
minutes to this at a time where you
should probably be allocating it to that
right to me I'm not willing to judge
myself and say that's a negative because
that's not real life like you don't
there's nothing there's no such thing as
perfect right and so I what I think is
super important is first and foremost
for everyone who's operating don't judge
yourself when things go wrong
literally right before Ryan the reason I
was exactly on time and not one minute
early to make sure you and your crew
felt good was I had a text as I was
setting up of a situation in my strategy
Department that's not going well
I'm a waiter than if I wasn't doing
seven thousand things
that that one little thing which is a
big thing could be going better because
I'd be closer to it but then I wouldn't
be doing seven thousand things so this
is very simple it starts actually in a
weird place which is the judgment on
oneself you have to fall in love with
micro losing to macro win
well I like that one I'm gonna note that
you type that down right now yeah I'm
gonna make that content
sorry this is how the magic gets made
um
it's how the brain works you have to
fall in love with micro using to macro
win okay
um so to me I'm micro losing all day
this up this sale was lost we
lost this client
then once you get over that hump and
realize as long as you go
get 11 wins and seven losses well you've
got plus four yeah the next thing is all
about your people like you've got to
think about loving them more than they
you work for them you love them once
they feel that they'll over deliver for
you
um and you'll just it's all about your
direct reports and then surrounding
yourself with people that are good at
the thing you don't like so if you don't
like operations and you're a Salesman
you have to hire a number two that is
obsessed with operations and doesn't
like selling
right if you bring in someone who's
operationally awesome and selling
awesome they're eventually not going to
Value you but we all know this one great
thing about sales is whoever can make
the money always has Leverage
no matter what no matter what everyone
here sucks at we can all sell and that's
a son of a right you know
that continue and we can then we've all
learned how to get better at other
and so keep those things important do
you value your sales skills as an
entrepreneur
number one
literally number two kindness I really I
know like this may seem fluff but I
really do think the reason I'm gonna
build a massive Empire is because I just
think I'm substantially nicer than most
people that can build Empires and I do
not think you've built a you just said
the reason you're going to do you not
think you've built a big Empire I know
that I built a big thing but I don't
think people understand how big what I'm
building is going to be does garyvee
have insecurity
of course but not in business it's been
the only place that I've been securing
my whole life you know I had way more
insecurity like asking a hot girl out in
high school than I did about making a
million dollars in high school
this has been my one safe place the you
know I got bad grades I lost in sports
like everybody else yeah I had plenty of
places that were telling me I wasn't
good the one place that has always told
me I was good was selling lemonade
shoveling snow selling baseball cards
building my dad's business building my
business like this has been my place
this is I genuinely believe in my this
is how delusionally
and it you know what's funny I'm saying
it by be trying to be self-deprecating
I'm actually going to be more
transparent I believe that I could build
the largest real estate company in the
world that's how much confidence I have
in my ability to go into any sector even
if it's not my sector
and because I've done it I went into
wine and built one of the largest wine
companies in the world I went into big
boy big girl advertising Madison Avenue
from from left field and have
built the largest independent company in
the industry very quickly I've made
myself famous on against against a lot
of people who say the way you were doing
it right with your face out there is not
the way to do it but you still made you
still found success and right you know
I'm gonna really give you some roses why
I said yes to this like I think you have
a lot of similar Elements which is why
what's happening is happening and so
anyway I need to go to the little guy I
love you guys I hope you enjoyed this
thank you for being here man I hope we
brought some value go enjoy your family
everybody else hang tight for two
minutes oh by the way here's the right
hook everybody was laughing I the reason
I want everybody to sign up for wanting
Texas two reason one you should all be
buying wine from my dad it's literally
365 deals a year one deal a day it's
like the old Groupon on text it's the
best but there's a different reason text
marketing done right yes could be the
single big this thing above even social
media so I think people should sign up
for it I know it doesn't work in every
state so I apologize but you should look
at it a you should always buy 50 wine
for 20 bucks or 100 wine for 30 bucks
clients events you literally save money
but B we literally look at 22 000 wines
a year right to offer 365. but two a
month of you consuming the text should
open up ideas why you should all do text
marketing
I love it awesome thank you
[Music]